staff at dozens of hospitals across
myanmar have walked off the job to
protest the military coup which ousted
de facto leader anson tsochi
healthcare workers accused the army of
putting their interests above coping
with the coronavirus pandemic
also on tuesday crowds staged the first
widespread protest
since the coup demonstrators banging on
pots and pans called for
suchi's release and the recognition of
her victory in november's
election well for more now we can speak
to journalist
dave grunibaum who's been covering the
country for several years he joins us
from kuala lumpur
dave what more can you tell us about the
protests
yeah well that's quite a stand last
night these were really where we started
seeing the
first signs of civil disobedience from
the public as you said people were
honking their horns they were on the
streets and from their balconies banging
pots and pans as a form of protest
and a myanmar civil disobedience group
said that at 70 hospitals and medical
centers as
you said in 30 different communities
across the country that doctors and
medical workers are not
working that they've walked off the job
additionally you may see
boycotts of military-linked products
this could include cell phone services
brands of beer the myanmar military
controls a vast
array of businesses across the country
now of course all this leads to the
natural fob question is
will we at some point in the days or
weeks ahead see mass mobilization mass
numbers of people
protesting in the streets of yangon and
other cities
in the country i've spoken to contacts
in myanmar today who tell me
there are discussions underway about
this but no decisions have been made
it would be quite a risk for these
people to take because if you look at
years past when there have been these
kind of protests
during the days of the earlier junta
they often respond with
not just violent force but often deadly
force so
there are some serious calculations that
have to be made if they want to go that
far
what about aung san tsuchi dave do we
know
where she's being held what's going to
become of her
well we're not quite clear on what's
going to become of her but a senior nld
official
did say on his facebook page that aung
suchi
appears to be in good health and that
she's been walking the grounds of her
compound
in napida the capital now of course
we've not heard directly from her since
the cous happened on monday
there was a statement that came out
shortly after the coup attributed to her
but that
statement was prepared in advance of the
coup as uh
she and her colleagues were anticipating
that it might happen
meanwhile the u.n security council dave
has failed to condemn the coup
with china blocking any action why do
they block it
well china has close ties to myanmar has
had closer ties
they certainly have business interests
in myanmar
economic political interests they during
the days of the earlier junta were
their close friends providing a lot of
economic support
during this transition over the last 10
years the transition that ended on
monday the transition democracy
they've been losing ground as western
countries have been getting more
influence inside myanmar
for china there's a chance to regain a
lot of that ground that they have lost
so that's a big reason why china you're
seeing a much more
tepid response here from them dave thank
you very much for your insights that was
journalist dave grunibaum joining us
from kuala lumpur
you